I think the typical censored looks nerdy
predominantly Caucasian I think I'm
gonna complete opposite spectrum of what
a fencer looks like acts like and is in
person I'm Marlon Watson I'm a two-time
Olympian and world champion as a trouble
9 after all I had to do a lot of
extracurricular activities those offered
in my middle school so I first picked up
a foil which is what they are like to
call a sword I just immediately fell out
with it I think we're taking this far
but uh I've ever won with ever since
people should know that fencing is it's
a combat sport I think it's super
thoughtfully all this will no it's
really intimate
you can literally hear them breathing
you can see their eyes you really see if
someone scared of someone's no emotions
and that's so cool about sport is you
can really gauge opponent emotionally
which I don't think you can amaze chords
well I think the fencing community
they've embraced me but they have people
obviously who older who want to see the
sport the same people have always said
like you won't win this competition you
want make a national team you won't ever
you know they can look a team you know
you won't be well champion I'm gonna win
just you teach Mickey either work-energy
motivators this just comes with the
territory
the first time I have a qualify for
Olympics it's just the most incredible
thing because all that hard work pays
off because 0.1% of the public goes to
the inputs
I think me out there just you have more
Drive than everyone else but you want to
prove you wrong